here with the defending winner of the
singfield cop 2021 maxine welcome to the
show tell us a little bit about your
preparation today of course you must
expect to berlin from wesley so what was
your choice
yeah i thought
you know this
was the most promising i i could find
and
yeah i assumed i'm slightly better but
i'm honestly a bit
annoyed at myself to say the least like
i think in some critical moment i didn't
think for long enough so um well let's
take a look at it first of all were you
familiar with this position that you
reached about this game christian
yeah yeah i was familiar
and tell us until more or less you did
not know what was going on
yeah so
a5 you played a4 yeah it's natural i was
not sure about if i thought maybe
rook c8 bishop a5 c5 was an idea and
instead of a4 in this position instead
of a5 instead of ah instead of a5
rook c8 here right away yeah bishop a5
and c5
because you want hook c6 i thought this
was maybe the rock c6 holding on to the
sixth fret like because often i want
bishop c3 so like after bishop f6 i
considered for a long time bishop a5
bishop a5 immediately yes but b6
bishop c3
take take
okay there's king e7
that i missed
with the age of rook f8
but
my point was after rook d8 i couldn't
find a win
right you probably have to go into the
pawn end game yeah and the opponent game
i thought could be promising but it's
not so right
it's a good thing
because i missed completely this idea of
kingston or cafe
um so anyway
yeah and after rugby two yes this
particular position so yeah
and here yeah i don't know what happened
to me so i i didn't see king e2 but
anyway
like
which is serious option probably draw
but you know
much uh
much more of a choice than what i did
but even after rugby 2 i thought hook d6
rook d6 in this position yeah i thought
for d6 was uh
you have to take yes hockey six rook e6
king f7 rookie four yes c5 bishop e1
two let's say yes catching the pawn yes
g4 g4 uh-huh cementing these ones yeah
take take bishop d4 a5
and well maybe it's actually nothing
because you're in time for bishop f6
bishop d8
but i saw very nice and you pick up the
pawn also
like no bishop d8 you have rocky five so
yeah but king g2 actually i i mean i
thought wesley was doing nothing in this
position so you know when i was thinking
after i played c3 because basically i
stopped
at c5 bishop he won
and assumed it was a draw but right
although it does think the engine does
think it's a draw anyway yeah yeah it is
but um yeah i thought sister made it a
lot easier but then yeah i should just
be annoyed that having missed kingitu
which
which was a more serious try yeah
probably draw anyway but interrogatory
and of course the pointless for the
audience is that after rook takes c2
rook d2 and k2 yeah and this enemy can
actually be very dangerous
it's not you know in dangerous realm
anymore yeah
that's true but yeah that's some peter
mentioned rookie two in this position
yeah and now with g6 uh it's completely
different you get the extra tempo
basically yeah yes all right
very good
well we're going to ask you a question
here from one of the other games turn
off the edges so can you get any hints
this particular position that we had
what were your thoughts looking at it
from a spectator point of view i thought
it should be fine for linear but at the
same time i feel like
fabiano looked at this sorry
and
yeah must have a comfortable uh way of
playing on so i think
uh if linear plays the best move
should still be within drawing margin
but it's quite unpleasant yeah he didn't
find the best move and after rook f8 uh
the entrance thought there was an
immediate win in this position okay
so yeah i thought hook effect was a move
so no rockefeller was definitely not the
move the engine is thinking instead rook
88 was the move only move to maintain
balance tough tough yeah tough but um so
look f8 i mean i didn't see a win
yeah the edge is thinking queen d7
logical or difficult to find uh
i mean definitely within like fabby's
abilities
[Music]
new
like if i go queen b6 you just won
knight f7 rook e7 yes
yeah and no perpetual yeah i mean
definitely i could expect furby to find
this still the engines like his position
a lot after the move rook d8 and g6 or
f5
yeah so g6 here i thought queen f6
that's the screen f6 and if one takes
hook e8
this one is yes
because after knight g6 i'm in time for
queen g6 yeah let's show that on the
board
and this is unclear but i don't think
black's in any danger
i mean white could be indeed yeah right
yeah
but instead i mean after all d8 maybe
you can take on c4 maybe you can do many
things maybe you can go king b1
it looks very dangerous
can be one anyway yeah
all right can you oh no
i can take on f4 but no no no you cannot
take on f4 let's show that right no this
this is what i thought this maybe i can
do but queen of four isn't it
yeah
g6 right away it picks up a couple of
pieces here and there maxime how do you
rate the start of your tournament
[Music]
a slow start let's say two draws
and today i'm definitely not satisfied
with you know alpha chance missed he's
still alpha chance right so you know in
this sort of tournaments whenever you
get off a chance you you want to take it
yesterday i feel like i played well
i took a lot of energy of course to
remember the details and uh well
actually to not remember some of the
details but
then i feel like i played a pretty good
game
but yeah i definitely like
need to
to rest to recover some energy
because for some reason i'm not sleeping
as much as i should here
and then uh then we'll see all right
well we'll let you get that rest on as
the commentators have any other
questions for you no you asked exactly
what i wanted to ask yeah i we wanted
the expert opinion on just how easy q7
is i don't think it's that
straightforward
but yes it should be findable i think i
think it's still surprised that five
didn't play it in particular since he
didn't blitz out queen e4 he definitely
considered his options there and if you
if you stop to consider
now also to me the question is like
how familiar fabi was this
uh
with the fact that rook f8 is not
a move
and therefore should be punished much
more harshly than with queen e4 well
we'll get to ask him after the game
certainly we'll let you get your rest as
it's a long tournament thank you for
joining us maxine thank you